so you leave tonight at 8 00 pm that's
right that's right
now and you're going to europe for two
weeks i'm going gone for two weeks now
going to europe
nowadays with covid is a situation
especially england still pretty pretty
tough everything is locked down you got
to have
so when you you before you go you have
to have a negative covet test
then you have to schedule a cover test
for two days after that
then you have to schedule another covet
test for eight days after that
okay and it doesn't matter if you're
going to go before you get on the plane
yeah now now if you now that doesn't
matter if you're going to he said
england wait guys i'm going to france
though after that
they go oh we don't care you got to sign
up and pay this just
it's a racket yeah and then you have
when you go to france a different rule
now you gotta have a vaccine card you
understand so you gotta show that
you know you don't get the france you
have to have a vacation or you don't
who knows they are it's random is it
worth it
do you need to go this bad listen
none of it's worth it but you know what
i'm saying you could just wait a year
i get to see my boy do this completely
yeah your boy's not going anywhere he's
not going anywhere
how old is he he's my age he's not going
anywhere you're gonna wait a year
yeah yeah no there's a lot of things you
could wait for yeah you can wait
you know i'm not good with vacation no
because everything stops and you know
when you love what you do
it is what it is i'm doing you know i'm
in philly
in front of a you know a packed crowd
there's nothing better that's
fun there's nothing better than that no
you know you're there for three days you
know it's not worth all the hoops and
stuff right
the only work that is involved is is
that plane and god forbid a shuttle
[ __ ] god shut up
you slit my [ __ ] throat i'll pay so
much money
then when i get on the shuttle oh
you got hurts what are you oh my god
what kate you're your
uh you gotta i'll help you with that
okay but lisa or you know what's
hey i'm gonna how long is the flight
it's 11 hours so you can wear masks for
11 hours sir now that's an issue too now
i'm going to try to what i'll try to do
is hold a bottle
open the whole time you know they get
they get they get privy to it they know
what's up
right eventually sir you can put your
message yeah because they know what
you're trying to do
yeah that's my i got a little that's my
mo i usually hold a giant messy cup of
coffee
and sit i'll i'll hold it here yeah
about an hour two hours like sweetie
some people have no problem wearing a
mask some people prefer it
i feel claustrophobic ah i can't breathe
i can't either so hot i see people
working out with a mask
that's amazing and they're happy to have
my girls signed up this new gym
and it's orange theory and there's they
have classes for people with mass
and people without masks so if you come
at noon
it's all mass yeah come at one there's
no mass yeah
how insane is that yeah well well then i
nothing
made me more uncomfortable with when i
have a waiter who would have two masks
on
and the visor and the visor was foggy
because it was hot
i'd be like jesus christ i'm gonna tip
the [ __ ] out of you
why jun why is there a skateboard in
here oh that's my
remember chappelle lacy that music video
yeah um
i just use it one time so i'm just going
to give it away to somebody that's cool
so i'm going to make a video you're
going to give
the skateboard away huh i can shave so i
won't use it
but um uh and there's nothing like and i
do judge anyone
in their 30s 40s with a skateboard yeah
that's why i'm giving away also
i remember when skateboards had the big
wheels the big polyurethane wheels yeah
now they're all thin wheels slime balls
yeah
and i don't feel like skateboard
technology has changed and iot
what should it since i mean there's
those electric ones
you've seen those the one big wheel well
i've seen the hoverboards
that actually you've never seen one of
them cover i've never seen one in person
i saw some girl
eat [ __ ] yesterday on a bird oh boy
[ __ ] and i saw her dad yelling at her
because dad was on the bike she was on
the bird
she ate [ __ ] so bad her shoes came off
and i sp i pulled over to see what was
going on oh boy is that guy
yeah so they need a ride or whatever you
know she ate
[ __ ] [ __ ] more people get [ __ ] up on
birds than that
wait what look at these things that's a
real uh hovercraft this one's a real one
yeah
this was in new york okay i saw i saw a
video
man oh that's green goblin basically the
spiderman villain green god the
spider-man villain green goblin
spider-man villain that's loud oh my god
it sounds like a lawn mower
strapped to his helmet because you're
basically riding flies
that's why it's not like a hoverboard
it's like a giant helicopter that you're
right that's what ups is gonna [ __ ]
yeah that's that's i thought there was
that hoverboard like back to the future
and they actually had those
that was a fake fake video oh really i
saw a video of a guy a car
oh yeah driving that transitions and it
gets wings
that was a lie too no that was no that's
real that's over in
europe somewhere i think it's slovenia i
told you me and clap had a buddy who
a guy i won't say slovakia who invested
his entire signing bonus he played in
the nfl
his entire entire signboast into flying
cars no he didn't
this was 10 years ago so they didn't go
over well somebody's got to talk to him
about that we thought it was smart
well it's the future dude well you would
think it is but then you get into the
like real like fly zones like you can't
fly over the city like
it's gonna be a nightmare see me at
night also with these particular
um cars you're gonna need a landing
strip it's not something where you can
just hover your way you're not
flying into your [ __ ] garage like
rick and morty yeah you would need to be
able to
land on a strip a buddy of mine came to
me
[ __ ] fun though yeah would you want
one yeah
hell yeah fly oh my god the freedom
dude if i had like real money i would
i would helicopter everywhere i would
too you know bill burr like flies that
helicopter
yeah just to [ __ ] around i'm scared
everywhere every helicopter is just too
scary
no but i put in like the ten thousand
hours to learn how to do it and then i
would just bank on myself then a few
diets on you so
i don't wanna die because of somebody
else mechanical failures though it
happens
yeah it does but you know what people
live in helicopters and don't die
you know what i mean that's true like
pilots it's actually just as rare as
anything else you just gotta
sometimes it's gonna happen and you know
kobe bryant didn't have you know
apparently
the pilot they were like this is a bad
day to fly
and it's kobe bryant the problem is the
pilot worked for kobe and cozy i don't
give a [ __ ] we're flying he's like
you're kobe bryant we're flying that's
what happens and he's like well it's
very foggy and i can't see the mountains
now we'll figure it out and then and you
won't you didn't figure it out and you
won't figure it out and i drive by that
mountain all the time do you really oh
yeah
you do it's calabasas oh tragic
yeah it's such a shame disaster desert
that's french
that's french um such a disaster i was
gonna ask you a question
about something something and i can't
remember somebody sent me uh
a video of buster keaton the oh the
charlie chaplin's
the the stunts that [ __ ] was
doing he's a real badass
it's the craziest [ __ ] i've ever seen on
my phone did you hear quentin tarantino
talk about
uh have you listened to it yet no god
it's good i listen out i got the book
i got the book but uh he was somehow uh
the stunt guys hated bruce lee he's
known as a dick
wow yeah he was like no stunt guy like
bruce lee really he was an [ __ ]
huh because he would like throw real
kicks and real
i guess he calls it tapping yeah that
means tagging tagging when you're really
hitting people
and bruce lee would do it all the time
so this guy's like i don't want to
[ __ ] work with him
so nobody wanted to work with him wow
yeah you know uh steven seagal does that
apparently
he'll he'll really hit guys yeah i'd be
worried about bruce because he knows
this [ __ ]
yeah um steven skull wait a minute are
you saying
you would you wouldn't have stephen up
on you
no dude have you seen him lately hey
have you
hold up have you ever seen thompson
girls bit on steven seagal
not bro i think it's from one of his
netflix specials
if you just type in thomas the girl at
steven's gault dude it is
[ __ ] hilarious it's so [ __ ] good
you can learn a lot from television for
instance without television
he looks so good i that steven seagal
is out of his [ __ ] house
we're alive sorry i've been doing
martial arts for like 85 years
just no effort just that good such a
beast
god damn that's a real comment ladies
and gentlemen tom
just can't talk when i first met him we
were on the road with rogan
and i would just watch him barely move
and crush rooms
like there's you know there's no pulling
rabbits out of hats just kind of almost
like i just woke up from a nap and now
watch me destroy he's a beast and he
does it all
he builds his hour on the road he's not
like a guy that goes to the store and
the story does it all on the road yep
but he was talking about what i did uh
two bears uh one cave i think it comes
out next week or two weeks
and he's talking about how he got his
first start he won a contest in irvine
a comedy contest to do two minutes with
rogan
and uh uh charlie murphy really so he
hosted that and he's like dude they gave
me two what are you gonna do [ __ ] two
minutes
so he said he goes up there does two
minutes and crushed for his two minutes
and then uh they brought him on again
and then in another city and then
afterwards rogan uh was like dude you're
really funny i'm gonna hit you up and
use you
and he's like i've heard that all the
times he's like okay rogan and then
charlie murphy's like i'm also gonna use
you
and then i'll you'll have to watch the
episode because it talks about how the
charlie murphy manager hated him so it
never happened but then rogan started
using him
yeah yeah yeah he's undeniable monsters
what i always say is if you want to get
ahead just become undeniable just be
really [ __ ] good well tom's the guy i
told ty it made him uncomfortable
he's my north star right like he started
his own network he's you know
he got big off his comedy specials like
he's one of the few comics you've got
sure specials
like sebastian like just funny as [ __ ]
like difference between him and
sebastian i mean obviously sebastian's a
[ __ ] monster yeah tom
pot i don't think people realize how big
tom's podcasts
are huge huh huge well that's the thing
your mom's house two beers one cave
he does the tom talks um i
i mean just between your mom's i mean
besides rogan out of our group he's the
biggest
wow by far wow i don't think people
really by far not even close
amazing tommy's the biggest yeah monster
well he's just undeniable
some people are that funny and he's
multi-talented he can just you know
just talk businessman too yeah yeah and
he knows his [ __ ] cars
he does oh man he knows his cars he
drives his gt4 i think it's a rs is that
your car
no how dare you no he sorry no i
actually wanted up him to it he's like
uh you and i was like i have a gt2 no
he has the gt-4 which is like the
smaller version
right they're monsters they're cool
they're just too small for me they're
too small too small
you can't fit in them i could it's just
similar but you don't where do you go
from that car where do you go my car
yeah
i mean as far as like race cars there's
nothing you can do you can use that i'm
gonna change the color on it that's
about it i i drove a porsche
it was a porsche turbo when it was a
long time ago my friend
had arnold schwarzenegger's porsche okay
that he had traded in
so he goes i got a surprise for you come
and thought i'd be like wow well
driving that thing at first and second
the gr d gear in los angeles was i i it
was like hey
all right five six speed being nightmare
but the new
turbos the new turbos daddy they're so
[ __ ] fast really they're insane they
can pop yeah but it's all
uh tryptopic now there's no like you can
get a gt3 touring in six speed and they
what's crazy is california was the only
state that made it illegal to have a
six-speed uh gt3 touring
because it's okay because he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and also because the guy
cuz he's a you know by the way how many
are there six of them so now you're like
protecting the environment like what are
we doing here but also like real like me
and my brother taught me this we both
want the new gt3 touring
he's just biting [ __ ] vegas register
it
as an automatic here if the cop pulls
you over you'd have to be a
cop who's really in tune with cars like
you got a six-speed touring man
and by the way and he'd probably be like
even then he's like this is awesome yeah
he's not gonna [ __ ] with you but how
ridiculous that they they wanted to
[ __ ] ban the six-speed touring
but what if they come up with an
electric car that
is have they come up with an electric
car that blows that away
speed wise for all those elections i'm
talking about i i i don't i don't
acknowledge them
but what about on the track man though i
mean those those uh
plaid uh teslas are a [ __ ] monster
and there's other uh
so that still doesn't matter to you you
like an engine no it doesn't count
they don't count they don't count really
no it's like those youtube fights they
don't count
yeah they're fighting they don't count
no no the real car the mechanic because
you want to be
you got to be like shifting gears and
all that it's part of how long we're
doing it with gas man you know yeah i
just don't they don't count
yeah and you need you do you like a
stick
love it because that way you can do that
feel everything yeah feel like you're
actually you're physically driving huh
well
you know what i find weird though jay
goes to those car like shows
yeah and there's one of the biggest ones
is malibu every sunday the
jay leno's there seinfeld the biggest
one
what i don't get is when these older
rich gentlemen pull up
and including the ones jay goes to in
california or colorado he goes
every week yeah when they pull up and
they have this weird
arrogance like they built the car yeah
you have nothing to do right with the
quality they're standing out inside of
the performance of that car
but you're yet you're posted up like you
hand built that thing well i see those
guys they got a little bit of a gut
they're wearing the jacket that matches
the car
no those are so this is what's funny so
there's there's groups right
yeah it's like larping there's grooves
yeah so already embarrassed by the way
when i see that it's
it there's a group i appreciate it but
there's a group so if it's
in jail tie this and must be unturned so
there
there's different genres of groups in
these car groups
so if you go by the porsche group
they're all friendly
pretty hard working there's no like
billionaires in the group like porsche
is a real man's car yeah and i have
and i have a theory like it's it's more
about substance right not as much about
its performance and we know our car is
reliable like we're not
[ __ ] german engineering it's
impossible it's the best of the best
cars are better not that flat that's a
monster which is why i have the gt2 it
looks you know
crazy but if you don't know cars people
yeah barely
i get more like thumbs up from my
defender than i do though
yeah so the porsche group they're all
together they're they're talking about
oh i did this or i'm doing this the car
and
you know i did this got this and then
there's like the the at the
uh mclaren similar but real ballers so
the mclaren group
very expensive even more expensive yeah
more expensive they're all together
like they're like they're all but
they're nice guys but they everyone
sticks together in the cross pollinate
mclaren and porsche
then there's the lamborghini lamborghini
i can already have a guinea
older coochie slippers gucci slippers
out of shape not
keto if you go hey what's under the hood
they have
no clue there it is they have no clue
and their hair is all slicked back like
mine
that's right yes that's right they're
usually like a gucci vest probably a
rolex that they probably don't even know
the [ __ ]
named lamborghini it takes a long time
to say it's already pretentious
and i love some lamborghinis but it's
it's it's especially like in the in the
in the car well it's kind of a [ __ ] boys
car because like
if you're a famous youtuber tick tocker
and you're going to get a car you're not
looking at gt3 touring you're not
looking at gt2 rs it's too many you
don't know
i'll guarantee they're getting a orange
lamborghini
yes and they're just like i'll take that
one and i will guarantee that their
their style
if you went to their house if you go to
a porsche guy's house the furniture is
modern
it's it's not wasted space the furniture
is comfortable
and it's it's solid if you went to a
lamborghini
owner's house i promised their their the
chairs would have
the swirly wood design it'd just be a
lot
and they wouldn't like it it's expensive
but they don't know why they got it
they're wearing gucci even though it's
not doesn't match or fit their stuff
they're wearing it because it has the
gucci logos on it
the gaudy goals it's a weird class of
yeah guys it's just different now what
about ferrari's kind of in the middle
that's what i was gonna ask you fries in
the middle
yeah because there are beautiful works
of art yeah
as far as italian goes with the best
anybody doesn't love a ferrari i'm not
even a car guy and i appreciate
a ferrari a 488 or like pisa f12
yeah the 812 super fast the station
wagon looking one i don't understand
so you're going to have the uh delia
yeah but if you're going to have to have
the other pokemon
yeah the kid the car seats in the back
really that's why you got it
oh is that right yeah you want to be a
[ __ ]
hot dad summer drive that [ __ ]
station wagon i feel like you that's a
terrible
no i think you don't think that thing
looks sick i don't like it no i think it
that the end the end of that car doesn't
belong on a [ __ ] ferrari it just
looks like somebody was like they what'd
you do
you put them on the wrong conveyor what
the [ __ ] now we got the back you know it
looks like
an suv back with a it's just [ __ ] if
you're gonna have a ferrari
have that back that beautiful tailpiece
you need a tailpiece on your ferrari i'm
not mad at that though that's
for a dad mobile maybe but i mean it's
so if you really want to get a dad
mobile you get the
e63 amg the four-door dad wagon what's
that
the lambo truck the lambo truck i'm
gonna try a little bit of [ __ ] boy that
car but yeah
yeah that's it that's at 400 000 but
here's a condo you can't you should get
a used one because lamborghinis don't
hold their value unless one of the
special ones
uh the here's the thing with kids that
you don't think about christians so like
my defender i can open up and when i get
my bronco
i can open up and hose down hose down no
problem wow
lamb you might dude i'll give my son ice
cream or something in the back
there's there's gummy bears from two
years ago back there there's
chocolate ice cream all over the seat
yeah i don't care
sunday i'll go spray it down you have a
lamborghini or you get that [ __ ]
that lavish and martin leather dude
nightmare it's
it's nightmare not for children i mean
you know it's not for churches
they're kids yeah and then kids it's imp
they're walking stains it's impossible
not to [ __ ] up i'll they'll get in the
car without food and i'll look back and
i'm like what are
what are those oh my god we'll just take
his shoes and just kick the back of my
chair
with his dirty feet of course mr
defenders are like whatever dude i guess
it works
yeah the defenders that car i've always
wanted because it's i've seen the
interior of that new one
oh yeah yeah you can hose it down yeah
well i looked at them too you can hose
it down
and you can have your dog it's like a
real truck yeah we don't have to worry
the bronco to the bunk only at the
it's not gonna have doors on top and
[ __ ] spray it down it's gonna be
great yeah
those are nice yeah when you like you
get that lambo or you get like that
[ __ ] royals royce or something dude
with kids are you kidding i mean i'm
tough
like gummy worms and like for whatever
reason like hides them
and then obviously forgets and then
where we live it gets a 120 degrees
so it like like my seats are like
[ __ ] super glued from
[ __ ] gummy worms dude i had to give a
[ __ ] yeah but if you have the money you
could always just pay to get it
detailed and cleaned and stuff if i have
the money for a lamborghini truck i'm
taking care of that like i'll get it
cleaned all the time i have dinner i'm
seeing a different tune with kiddos man
john lovitz shows up i go to dinner
right john lovitz yeah and we have
dinner and he's in a
he's in a jacket and he's got this very
expensive and he looks at me he goes i
came
in a rolls royce can i go
i thought he was joking i go you did he
goes yes he's so funny and he looks over
there and i look at this
brand new rolls royce it was the suv or
the it was it was the car
and then i sat in it after we had dinner
he made me laugh the whole dinner he's
[ __ ] hilarious just
saying things like that well i'm very
rich
you remember when me and him had that
weird tiff remember that
you don't remember that no years ago
and this one i was like oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
kid don't [ __ ] around the fans don't
year dude five six years ago
uh my mom she's never seen me do stand
up she came to see me do a set at the
laugh factory
and she saw john lovitz oh sorry john
less doesn't know
who my [ __ ] promise but my mom the
reason i was so interested live is that
was our thing as a kid we never missed
silent life for like [ __ ] 10 years
every saturday so she saw she sees him
freaks out
but she's across the street and she goes
john and he you know he's like he went
like
ugh like you know oh whatever my mom was
so
pissed and embarrassed so she told me
i'm like what the [ __ ]
so then i was pissed i'm like no wait
john dude he's so nice
i'm telling you that's what he [ __ ]
blew me off i'm like what the [ __ ] so we
i go on the podcast
on that following monday and i'm like
john levs did this didn't think anything
of it
remember john reached out to he was like
what the [ __ ] i'm getting blown up
i'm getting all these this hate on
social media man from brendan's fans and
i'm like yeah what
yeah remember that i knew and he then we
called him we didn't
call him because john is the kind of guy
who's he's like honestly so funny
people say hi to him all day he's going
to do a set yeah i get it and he's like
hi i don't yeah but a lot of even that
he'll be silly about you know
remember we saw him at the donut shop oh
yeah yeah he tried to fight us
he got into a karate stance yeah
yeah he's like i practice karate now
he's looking
[ __ ] funny he i sat in that car
though that car handmade that that rolls
royce
it's a museum i don't know what i do in
that car because i'm afraid of
but everything is every detail it's not
for me i don't like those i'm more of a
bentley guy but
um that stereo's got something to say
though yeah they're great
yeah oh there he goes he put his podcast
link in there and that's not how that's
basically no that's cool that's
hilarious an older that's basically the
only word guys
with my friend here with my friend
kendra wilkinson
hello kendra hello john i'll be
performing at the west palm beach improv
yeah february 8th 9th and 10th oh my god
that's january
2018. so he's not been posting i'll say
he didn't post a lot
he's an older dude yeah that's 2018's
last one look at this terrible picture
of his dog
he's just an older man he has a dog bed
and his dog comes with him everywhere
everywhere
yeah so i was like all right legend
a legend a legend didn't he used to have
a
jesus christ he's a lucky cow my great
pal lucky gal didn't he used to have a
comedy club out here
he did for a while and then i think he
got embezzled and somebody embezzled
uh i think somebody took stole money was
stealing money and he was like
um what's going on here i don't and he
had to close
oh you mean he's not the best bejesus
all right get her out all right who is
that
leona she's a recording artist
apparently all right of course
i'll listen yeah do you do you see how
many uh
you probably didn't see you see how many
people are pissed at the little nos x
at the bt awards he kissed a guy on
stage he did and
parents especially the right it's
[ __ ] irate about it
really yeah interesting like you're
you're influencing our kids you know
is he the one who's staying at uh you
know that the rodeo
yeah yeah yeah yeah but he came out as
gay and you know
yeah which is not easy in still in the
black community in hip-hop
yeah it's it's still it's just it's a
pretty conservative but my thing is
is if you're gonna get mad at a little
nausea oh like you gotta pick your
poison here because you know if you get
mad little
nauseas doing gay stuff which he's a gay
man that's his right to do
and it's 221. so if you're worried about
little nausea
influencing your kids but you'll let
them listen to rap where they're talking
about murdering and selling drugs and
killing people that's okay
okay so there's a lot of gayness going
on there though that the whole thing was
basically
men around him he's a gay man yeah
i mean and there and then the madonna
tweet uh what she did she tweeted like i
did it first
yeah she's not a gay woman of course
she's of course madonna it was more of
like a
cry for attention rather than her
training madonna that's crazy
remember when she photoshopped her face
so [ __ ] true it's just a whole thing
and
that didn't really cause an uproar when
madonna and uh brittany kissed
we were just like all right two hot
chicks yeah yeah
yeah then i don't know
it is what it is hold on this is it here
all right
he goes pretty hard oh well that's a
real kiss there yeah i mean
i mean by the way if you got a kid and
you're you're going deep
you're bob slapping hard like that
you're really kissing
i could get why people would be like i
mean like
even if it's a girl guy it's it's a
little it's a little pornographic
i don't know i guess but my daughter my
daughter
knows every word to wet ass [ __ ] yeah i
have a problem with that
but i also gave up i'm also like i give
up i [ __ ]
you can't say what the [ __ ] am i gonna
do now you know you took the internet
took
everything away from me including the
sacred space between my daughter she was
[ __ ] singing
every word and i'm sitting there like
this like you know what i could do about
that
i could do about as much i i was
basically a cow chewing grass
just no i'll just be over here chewing
my cud because i can do nothing as a
father
too [ __ ] say i'm gonna back you i'm
[ __ ] done anime
and then she's in the anime these are
middle schoolers
oh well not only that anime is like well
um my favorite is todoroki he killed his
parents because uh so he's an anti-hero
and uh and he also cuts himself because
he
i'm like the [ __ ] is going on it's the
dark anime
anime is dark right yeah oh well there's
different types of anime so it's really
up to
what the specific person likes it sounds
like your uh daughter's into like
a dark [ __ ] dude and so are her friends
okay and they sit around
until she runs with the weird posse they
listen to a wet ass [ __ ] and watch
she's like they're wrists yeah it is
it is on the move the cool chicken like
my daughter
all her friends yeah they're they're all
women i don't know man
bro girls
in middle school that first of all they
know everything
because they have the internet okay
second of all
they are like she's like yeah and then
she's talking about
[ __ ] androgynous japanese assassin boys
and i don't have anything in common with
that and what happens is
what's hard for you when you got little
kids so you can cuddle and talk and
everything
what's gonna happen is that you are
going to find yourself
that's in a situation with your children
where you have zero in common boys might
be a little different your kids will be
athletes
girls are but they're also into what i'm
into listen my daughter's what's your
wife
she's a jock she loves lacrosse she's
obsessed with the cross she watches
d1 women's lacrosse makes me watch it
she's got opinions she's always
practicing i get it
but there's i can't even relate to the
lacrosse you're not i can but i'm saying
there are just things that that the
internet brings into her life
and you will have [ __ ] all to do with it
watch this so she always says y'all and
what i realized is that instead of
saying she says y'all because you guys
is gender specific
so she's being gender sensitive oh
interesting yeah bro and you're like
because she was reading um uh fantasy
novels and they have a large queer um
presence in fantasy novels so she's like
reading this stuff
and she's like well these girls are
kissing so she then what does she do she
goes to youtube
and goes down that rabbit hole and now
she's a trans activist
is she is she now she's treated girls
i don't know man you're asking me
questions i don't want to answer right
now
i believe she's in the boys she's not
into anybody she doesn't seem like she's
gotten that stage yet dude just go no
a road you know i'm not saying a bad
road
you're being just going down a road
you're being antagonistic to me right
now sounds like your dog's going down
the
no no no no no we gotta we gotta edit
that out i
no i'll get [ __ ] for it now listen up
here's the thing you [ __ ]
i don't know what's going on all i'm
saying is they grow up way too fast with
the internet
day yeah and i have nothing to speed
things up yes
because you're not there when they're on
tick tock and going down the different
rabbit holes
that they're going down but i just know
that she will not read jk rowling
anymore because apparently jk rowling is
uh transphobe and i'm like no she's not
and i don't know what to say about it
so dicey how about have you heard the
lyrics to wet ass [ __ ] it's outrageous
no the whole thing is [ __ ] crazy when
and her and her friends they just know
i'm like you can't sing that in the car
you can't see that in my back seat when
i'm driving you can't do it and they
i gotta set the no they're just doing it
because it's bad
yeah like like with a little nuts it's a
little nozzle and snoop dogg when we
were kids
my my nine-year-old is listening to
little knots little nas
is is because we have the streaming so
he hits it lil knows that song uh
cocaine now oh call me by your name yeah
it's like the song
all that and i'm like my nine-year-old
is like i love this song i'm like i i
can't i can't do this
i caught it bad yesterday i hit me in a
place and being a while i'm going to
catch a
romantic talking you're cute enough to
[ __ ] with me tonight
looking at the table oh i see as weed
and white maybe you're living the life
but
you ain't living right cocaine and
drinking with your friends
you live in the dark boy i cannot
pretend i'm not fazed
only here to sin if eve ain't in the
game this is a
gay man it's actually good [ __ ]
lyrics by the way but
are you in now are you in i'm 54.
my nine-year-old i just don't want my
nine-year-old to be like play that song
again
but is he in anybody else or
is he into anything else yeah he's in
other stuff bro he's in the hard rock
that's what he likes most of all yeah
are you in the hard drive no he likes
hardware
dude no he loves led zeppelin ac dc no
no he likes you
he likes little knots and that's fine no
he likes hard rock too he likes hip hop
and hard rock
and he likes to and then i can't talk to
him when he's listening to music
he's in the back seat and i'm like how
was your day goes don't talk to me right
now
i'm grooving the music so he would
rather
we're very similar he and i it's the
problem i talk to myself right i'm i'm
i'm never there right and i'm i'm never
we're driving never present yeah
and and we're driving and and i
and i realized that i'm [ __ ] having
my own conversation is he present in
school though
sort of like i was the answer is no yeah
and then i look in the back seat and the
motherfucker's talking to himself just
like me
and i was like wow and then i call he
said in your own world he goes
yup literally my favorite thing to do
i'm like all right well my kid's gonna
be just like me
and i hope he can navigate the world so
let's see what happens it's out of state
by the way
how about this stand-up comedy that
[ __ ]
is it's so weird to see your little your
clone
all he does is make his friends laugh
every one of them they're like he's
hilarious they all want to be around him
because
he's he that's he lives to make people
laugh and he's got a pretty
sophisticated sense of humor
he does characters so it's it's weird
when
uh other parents just let [ __ ] slide
like my kid does jutsu and there's one
kid who just
he doesn't listen and dad's like yeah i
was just like i'm like yeah that's fine
dude
but [ __ ] get the kid in line dude yes
like or why bring him
yes like if he's not gonna do what the
other kid's doing why bring him in i
believe in discipline like that
i have to i mean or don't count but a
lot of people but a lot of parents don't
there's a school of thought that kind of
says it's like two ways of thinking
right they're two schools of thought one
is like and it's actually kind of a
conservative liberal kind of mindset
so like like if you ever think about
conservatives they're like we need law
and order
you gotta have law and order and you
gotta have rules church and all that
stuff because what happens is
if you let people just do their thing
they'll be [ __ ] in the streets and
shooting everybody
and liberals tend the other that that
mentality is like wait a minute
that's all restriction you put your
religious direction let me know let me
breathe and be loose
yeah well yeah but some people are
either one side of the other
man and it just depends on if you think
people and i think it just depends on
the person some people
don't need chains other people need some
[ __ ] they need something
what do you need some guidance yeah yeah
the [ __ ] that's good for you
like i have this joke where it's like
when you're young if it feels good
you're like this is the truth let's move
in together who needs money
we have each other when you're older and
something feels good you're like the
[ __ ] is the catch what's going on who's
paying for this
you know and that's really true you
don't trust things that are that feel
good because
there's got to be a price to pay do you
watch dark anime cat and that weird [ __ ]
no my sister does though i never really
got into anime i'll watch some
here and there if i'm in the room with
her but she's more of the anime geek
anime i'm comic book thing right yeah um
are you a banana maker i want to say
it's like necessarily that of a younger
thing
i think a lot of people older were into
anime but it was a secret because it
wasn't cool back in the day now anime is
cool so everybody's into it
it's a classroom of assassins yeah she's
[ __ ] watching i think it's called
assassination clash
but what's the difference between that
and comic book nerds right
no it's not yeah but it's pretty what is
this now the most common mantra
categories
demographics kodomo is which i don't
know children
under about 10. yeah well my daughter's
into
the assassins i don't know which one's
the
shows you and she's into anti-heroes not
heroes and she can tell you what an
anti-hero is
is anti-hero hero a villain uh it's a
type of villain it's
he kills people he kills people it's
like dexter yeah he's a
anti-hero yeah he's a hero but he's a
bad guy yeah well he's been so destroyed
as a kid
that now he's his darkness has to find
an
outlet now he kills dark [ __ ] yeah
that man is an anti-hero like those
types of people yeah getting into it
the dark knight i mean i love comic
books as a kid growing up
loved him yeah so i guess it's similar i
don't really [ __ ] with comic books now
whatever you don't see a lot of comic
book stores
driving uh off venture the other night
last night taking my son jiu jitsu we're
driving back
i saw a spy store i wanted to take a
picture like how much money is this
[ __ ] place
a hundred dollars a month yeah it was
like spy gear like glass is the camera i
remember that
people still i don't know you know
there's a guy uh i was i was asked to
and
my friend of mine just found this out i
don't know if i told you this and he was
uh asked to invest
in well there was this this guy who had
this idea and it was like the uber for
private eyes
where you could hire a private detective
for not a lot of money
to like investigate something so follow
your girlfriend if you thought she was
cheating on you or
[ __ ] follow an insurance guy or
whatever it was you know
and it was kind of an interesting idea
because if you wanted like an app
yeah it's like an app and you could just
hire a licensed
livestream well the thing is there are a
lot but but but they
it's kind of a hard thing to do and it's
expensive but he's like there are people
who
can get you can get your license pretty
quickly and they'll take pictures or
follow us
yeah yeah but it would be something like
chiropractic but a lot of people would
have
a lot of people would probably if it
cost you a hundred bucks to have someone
follow for the night that you thought
was [ __ ]
[ __ ] you over you might do it you
know it's got it seems to have legs
sort of so anyway he goes um he goes
i'm not feeling it well so my buddy puts
300 grand in and he's got money he's got
money so here's my despair
yeah and this guy's raising money and i
meet the guy you know and he's
and he's he's emailing me and stuff and
you know you just sometimes you just get
a feeling
yeah i'm like i don't know man you're
just too familiar and cool and you're
saying all the right things
anyway he's in jail now for eight years
sir for what fraud yeah yeah yeah so
that'd be eight years
yeah they're like you tell me the uber
spy investigating
[ __ ] didn't work out it didn't work out
it's like some of those things are like
anytime there's an app i always think
that's a great idea the problem is i
gotta download it
on my phone and do this now it seems
like not a lot
it's a lot it's something about
downloading absolutely so if it's a good
app
you'll make if it's a good app you will
but there have been a lot of good apps
that don't
catch on or just it takes a while or
then it's
another kind of thing coming 21 though
if it's a good app
i mean that's where it's at what's what
are the like ways i would use all the
time depending you know certain apps
but ways is cool ways is stressful
because you drive to someone's front
[ __ ]
dining room to get to your destination
yeah wait wait it's so stressful
right now left right left left right
take your right through the hood
that's my thing it needs to be like hey
how comfortable are you in these
certain dangerous areas yeah are you
with your kids and family
yeah and sometimes it shaves off 30
seconds or a minute it's
way too stressful yeah it's [ __ ] so
this is exhausting but like the
iu well uber of course uber and
instagram
all those wraps but uh the best app for
like if you're doing a diet is uh called
uh
fitness pal it's really good they they
cover everything they can
find calories for everything micros
everything and but you can say i weigh
this much i want to weigh this much
they'll say okay you need to eat this
many calories a day and then
it'll have everything like if you work
out how many calories you
you'll burn it has your water intake and
then
what would you wear a watch no not at
all it's just on your phone you have it
yourself so you have to monitor yourself
so
breakfast lunch dinner and snacks and
then it has every so if you have
chipotle you can bring up you can type
in chipotle and have the entire menu you
can figure out how many calories you ate
you ate and everything
i'm going to track it down to the mouth
i'm already out there that's too much
work
mark put me on to that yeah i've been
using probably four weeks now it's great
yeah and it's dope because like let's
say
like yesterday i had uh it's my favorite
that's why i text you last night cat
because we were talking about natural
chicken hot sandwiches i was talking
about their dads at the jiu-jitsu place
and i was like i know natural chicken
[ __ ] hot sandwiches like going to go
to dave's i was like [ __ ] dave go to
al's hot chicken
like really i'm like it's literally
dave's is here al hot chicken is here
so the competitors off ventura like you
go to owls it's
besides the one we go to i can't
remember the name of it helen raise
colin raise
helen ray's pound for pound probably
number one but al's is right there
and there's no go hot so al's is hotter
than helen ray's
like the mild is tricky are you gonna
meet him i like really hot stuff i can't
eat al's hot
chicken sandwich i can't get through it
how i'm raised i can eat and i'll be
okay i might [ __ ] my pants out the back
but but you survived
owls i can't finish oh wow that's a
highlight and if you eat the hottest
last one you have to sign a waiver
yeah a lot of places will do that now
with the hottest one you have to and i
couldn't get through that
and i was like what do i do get the hot
one she's like you gotta sign a weight
room like oh that's not for me
and i like hot [ __ ] usually if you sign
a waiver they make you uh
wear gloves too yes oh so it's like
pepper spray basically
yes basically but as far as like taste
and like the bun
and the everything on it al's hot
chicken adventure is the [ __ ] spot
really oh it's nice what diet are you on
right now
macros so i can eat that sandwich but i
entered in it's like 670 calories
you know so that means that's probably
the rest of the food for the night but
thursday's immaculate so just you just
kind of macross proteins
carbs that's it so but i have to stay
under 200 calories which i've done for
four weeks now
really so that's enough for you because
you're a big guy well i'm trying to lose
weight
so if if uh if i eat that 670 calories
that goes into that
2200. what about the idea that you you
eat no bread and stuff just vegetables
and
won't you shred up if you just eat
protein it's unrealistic though
yeah how long are you gonna do that how
long do you wanna do that this diet this
macro diet i can eat
i can have howl and raise they're like
tiger wanted ice cream last night if he
does get in jutsu they do this thing
where they go back to back with the kids
and they flip and they gotta push
one down if he wins that i give him ice
cream to motivate him to win it he's won
every time since he destroys his kids
because he knows he's gonna get
chocolate ice cream because at first
he's so friendly he'll just like
whatever bring him into his garden like
dude you got you're way bigger and
stronger these kids you got to turn
around
so we're working on turning around
grabbing the lapel and push them down
and i'm like if if you win because they
do four i go if you at least win three
you'll get ice cream dude
killing it for beating the show these
kids because he knows he can get
chocolate ice cream he's got papa's
genetics
yeah he's a monster yeah but i can get
uh i can have like a little ice cream
look how many calories i have and i can
have that ice cream on these other diets
you can't
but again it's as long as i'm with my
macros i stand under 2200.
however you want to get there it's up to
you but you're under 2200.
wow and then you get more calories like
i'll work i'll do cardio in the morning
so i'll burn four or 500 calories on the
stairmaster so that adds into
2200 that's you know 2 600 so you can
cheat a little more what are you
weighing right now have you weighed
yourself oh
i stick the diet and work out every day
what do you want how much you want to
lose
you sweet you got a little tummy time no
no not at all so what
cosmetically you just want to shred up a
little bit yeah just feel good i feel
better my energy's better
yeah cool have you guys read that um
gary taub stuff
you know gary thompson yes jerry tops so
he says bad calories yeah so good fat
great
calories not a calorie so basically if
you carbs let's say your 2200
limit if you eat carbs versus proteins
you get way more benefit and weigh less
fat storing it because of the carbs yeah
yeah because because you know those two
books are
pretty revolutionary really good because
and that's like what a lot of guys will
do now because
what happens is if you eat say a bowl of
like if you
a bowl of dough versus a bowl of
broccoli the dough
creates an insulin reaction exactly you
store more fat right for whatever reason
when the insulin is attached to the cell
you don't use the fat stores in your
body what you want to do is be running
on fatty acid fatty acids not glucose so
when you eat foods that are glucose
sugar yeah you need to replenish so when
you eat muffins you're going to be
hungry an hour later
when you eat an omelet with just
vegetables that's why he says vegetable
that's why slow carbs are what they call
slow carbs and and that that's how
that's
basically how you do it and i've done
all that stuff i'm sure it's great i've
done all that
literally all that stuff and this is the
that this micro
diets the only especially when you're on
the road all the time which coming up in
august i'll be on the road all the time
yeah it's the only one that's realistic
and i
know this stuff is not real i i think
the best thing to do is literally track
your calories because that's
legitimately what actually makes a
difference if you're if you're
2 thousand calorie diet that's gonna be
fine like how you get there you're gonna
lose you're fine yeah
although you can read all those books
you can do this carby don't
get the [ __ ] out that's what i did too
so yeah okay under 200 000 calories or 2
200 000. stay under 2 000 calories
you're gonna lose weight
before though i'm not hungry dude no no
ever
never eat later in the day too that
helps a lot yeah
and then if you don't eat breakfast
right uh sometimes i have protein shakes
and then sometimes
uh i'll have like 1400 calories to go
because if you're it's bad if you're
honest yeah it's a bonus so i can have
cherries or boba or whatever
because bo was 400 calories whoa yeah
that's that tea
yeah i love it pistachio you know number
one there's too much sugar in that one
but
do you know there's a shortage on the
floor yeah there's a boba shortage yeah
so because i always get extra boba and
like what is boba
now online people are making their own
boba at home oh really yeah it's tapioca
balls
you know the
are they bad for you yeah they're bad
for you yeah they're not great it's
basically pure sugar right it's like uh
just sugar and carbs yeah
but they're so good once in a while it's
fine it's 400 calories
there's a good opposite around the
corner here probably
both at times cool yeah yeah they're
[ __ ] nice though they're so good
what's your mobile order almond milk
without your bubba
solid almond milk tea without your butt
i judge people based off of their boba
order
i don't like grape i don't i don't like
dairy [ __ ] i don't have any dairy ever
there's a place i'm have a kitty now
it's a pudding place
well that's gonna be ready for two
months dude it's called
it's japanese or something something
called kudu pudding or something like
that
on advocacy just pudding it says great
coffee and
pudding and you see this thing you walk
in there it's like yeah
maybe that's what it is i don't know
kudu pudding i don't [ __ ] know
yeah and so i'm like god it looks fancy
too yeah and
i i i mean i don't know like
i don't see a long line out the door i
don't see a line
out the door i'm not eating blue pudding
no i just i'm like mmm
pudding huh what's in the pudding let's
see what's in it
when you do a top one first the first
one has to be loaded with calories
caramel popcorn pudding caramel fudge
that's pretty [ __ ] lit
yeah but again it's pudding yeah and so
it's
like i got ice cream i got salt and
straw right there
i don't know if i'm going to pudding
like if i said ice cream or pudding
you say that's my kid my kid's gonna get
the [ __ ] out of here
pudding you know pudding is what you
have when you don't have ice cream
you don't see a lot of pudding either
just the whole thing i don't want to
talk about it
if i can't you when i go through it's
gonna be good for a business now hear me
out put on
i got i want to make i want to make pies
and pudding and put it and say well it's
not 1940. if i did this though
i did this even better i went hey i'm
going to have a store
i'm only selling pudding let's say
you're you're gonna be open for about
four months yep it's a pudding
after the four months to get dicey the
best thing is they open it up and then
kovac shut them down so it was just
sitting there for a year and a half
yeah now they came roaring back well
there you go
another one that's tough gelatin
cornstarch
have you had those uh i don't they're
not keto they're like the healthy uh
pop-tarts the protein pop-tarts oh yes i
did i tried the strawberry one
it's pretty good for protein they're
good we had the gym mark and all the
guys we got done lifting like they're
passing out those [ __ ]
protein pop tarts and i'm good they have
20 grams of protein i don't know
i said you ever had a real pop tart and
then one kid's young his name's isaiah
he's like 21.
he was no are they good i go he's never
had a podcast
no he's never had one like you will
never eat that protein [ __ ] again [ __ ]
off with you he's like they're that good
i'm like yeah dude
it's a [ __ ] pop-tart yeah i'm not put
that thing in the toaster they're
fantastic yeah stop trying to reinvent
the wheel i don't give a [ __ ] about your
protein pop-tart
i get depressed with that stuff that one
looks good yeah it does
but it's basically a little purple right
it's a bunch of swords
no there's no soy in there soy what are
you [ __ ] vegan
i don't know that's what they do i think
it has pea protein in it
all right so people nice again it's like
i mean for what it is for what it is
it's good i gave myself i don't get i
guess
he just needs some milk he never had a
pop-tart i mean
he never forgot it he was like where are
those uh
he comes he didn't like it he loved it
he freaked out
yeah it changed everything but have you
have you given your son a toaster
strudel
no duh [ __ ] screaming a toaster
yeah here's your thing stop having a kid
listen to a little nausea and give him a
[ __ ] toaster
yeah he's a goddamn american that's what
you're gonna do black coffee
yes toast shoes are so good dude i swear
on my
me and my brother when i skip my [ __ ]
by him is because
we get the toaster strudels and i love
icing it's till this day
you'd use two of them i'd use four
icings on one toaster's doodle brendan
and so by the time he got to the end
there'd be like four just the strudels
and no [ __ ]
icing he would straight beat me up over
it god damn but it was so worth it no
that looks good though
oh dude what yeah when they come fresh
out of the [ __ ] toaster and it burns
hot tongue
and then you burn the the but it's worth
it help the [ __ ] icing on top
dude i used to get beat up that's how
much it was worth
i would take an ass weapon to use extra
icing jesus that was fantastic
i was like [ __ ] bringing it back i'm
the guy i would do it again yeah i'm the
guy that takes the icing off the oreos
it was too much for me
i was never good with a lot of sugar
yeah you don't like icing
i just did a lot of that was too much
like the toasters i would have been like
oh this is super sweet even as a kid oh
no it was a bit of a finicky eater a
little bit of a kitty cat
oh wow yeah you you bear huh you
couldn't get another
berry you don't have sugar i'm not too
worried about sugar and kids
i've seen so much [ __ ] yesterday the
poor did an
hour off it's summer camp from nine to
four then he had jiu jitsu at six
in an hour off yeah dude their their
schedules get too packed
well mine was packed too as a kid but
you know sugar he's gonna burn off in
jiu-jitsu i'm not worried about it
yeah ever apparently if you're more
muscular naturally you have more
glycogen
to feed your muscles so you do better
with sugar yeah so
sometimes like people who are sprinters
can
work with sugar better than people who
are oh is in your current events
homegirl who broke the record
getting yeah care you need to stay
healthy shouldn't be that tough
shouldn't be that tough y'all or
expensive everyone should be able to
afford their medications
check out goodrx they help me find the
lowest price on my prescriptions
every freaking time with goodrx you can
instantly compare prices
for your prescription at every pharmacy
in your neighborhood and save up to
eighty percent
eighty percent good rx is free and easy
to use
many times it's often cheaper than using
your insurance copay or medicare
with goodrx you can find discounts of
your prescriptions at over 70
000 pharmacies cvs kroger walgreens rite
aid
bonds walmart wherever you're going
they're probably there good rx is the
number one most downloaded
medical app and millions of americans
use goodrx to get affordable health care
every month start saving up to 80 on
your prescriptions today
go to goodrx.com fighter that's
goodrx.com fighter goodrx.com
fighter good rx is not insurance but can
be used instead of insurance
in 2020 goodrx users receive an average
savings over 70 percent of retail prices
goodrx.com fighter
summers here man you don't be that dork
with his shirt
tucked into his frickin pants you wanna
be that guy with a tucked in shirt at
the barbecue
nope you want to look fly man that's
where ontucket comes into play here
they have performance shirts that wick
the sweat swing outside
flipping burgers on the grill you can
look fly doing it and you're also not
sweating out the shirt
they have short sleeve button downs
polos that are made to beat the heat
untucked shirts are perfect as we
transition back into things
that we've been missing like dinner with
friends reuniting with family
barbecues vacations whatever you're
doing do it with on tucket
onto shirts are made to be worn untucked
they fit all shapes and sizes ontucket
offers up to
size xxxl for the big boys for you
thickies out there plus they have slim
relax tall fits we got you covered
ontucket has 85 stores nationwide
free returns and exchanges so if you
want to untuck your shirt and
fly around the barbecue this summer use
code fighter for 20 off your first
purchase at
ontucket.com that's ontucket.com promo
code fighter for 20 off
so sometimes like people who are
sprinters can
work with sugar better than people who
are oh always in your current events
homegirl who
broke the record yeah for weed yeah she
did
you thought it was like uh he's like
okay call me before you roast us for
abandoning this girl for testing
positive
i'm like over weed dude there's a lot of
outrage right now it's 2021 man
you guys are still testing for weed no
and how would weed
enhance her running wait a minute so she
doesn't get to go to the olympics
no because uh when news broke out people
thought
that record away from it no people
thought that she
uh had tested positive for steroids
because they just said that she tested
positive for drugs it later came out
that it was positive because she smoked
marijuana
and that is a 30-day suspension
and the issue with that is it would be
suspended in
she could serve her suspension out in
time to go to the olympics but then she
would miss
trials and if she doesn't qualify for
trials she can't run in the olympics so
at the end of the day she can't go
anymore that's [ __ ] outrageous
a bunch of people are saying like she
also just lost her mom
oh yeah but but then also and then she
ran and she won but she can take
[ __ ] uh cbd well cbd but
so she could do painkillers and she can
be fine
a lot of people are complaining saying
that russians can take steroids but
americans can't
take [ __ ] no it's such a sad story
this poor girl
god a lot of people are rallying behind
her right now which is
good but yeah it's unfortunate so that's
it so she's [ __ ] done it's over
they can't do anything all that practice
and she's not allowed to [ __ ] even
compete
and she was a favorite right she is the
fastest she's going to win gold she's
right
it's a beautiful story though oh my god
it's an absolutely beautiful story
can't these [ __ ] like bend the rules
i mean
maybe this might change it though who
knows this particular
i remember a long time ago 20 years ago
when uh he was a sprinter and he
and he had a false start but it turned
out it wasn't it turned out
he was so fast the machine didn't
[ __ ] record it
and they disqualified him and he'd stand
there and he wouldn't get off the track
he's just standing there with a shirt
holding it onto it and he threw it in
the trash
ten seconds remember that seinfeld
episode
which one where jerry beat the guy
racing on a street race but then he got
a false start
there is a great episode you're going to
watch it false start all that [ __ ]
that's such a bummer i know this is
terrible that's like that's
olympic swimming the difference in first
place and fourth place was two
blinks of an eye that
nice now come on fourth place no metal
and then
this is insane so this is a video that
looks like it was filmed on a potato
yeah um this happened i believe last
friday
in the red sea two palace parasailers
were
on their way down and a shark came out
and bit one of the
parasailers on the floor it didn't rip
his leg off but it did
rip a part of the back of his foot off
and i was insurgent shortly after oh
kind of shark big boy uh they don't know
what type of shark it was probably el
tigre
it said red sea right so yeah this is a
red you got a lot of bull sharks a lot
of tea grace bull sharks are brown there
yeah el tigre [ __ ] videos in this
area said they've never seen anything
like this and they wouldn't have had
believed it if it wasn't for
the footage but the footage then looks
okay i'm gonna i'll be i'll tell you
when i see it i'm
actually yeah let me see this thing i'm
going el toro yeah we're shark
yeah i think dude i swear to god if it's
like a [ __ ] i'm then shark i'm gonna
freak out
you're not gonna be able to tell what
type of shark it is oh well it could be
swimming because you see that though
you can see something jumping out but
you can't really tell it's a shark oh
that could be a bigfoot i don't know
oh that's a big [ __ ] yeah is it a great
white are there great whites in the red
sea oh yeah
it's right there are you [ __ ] kidding
me that's a horror show he probably
thought it was a bird
floating over the top maybe but that
scares the [ __ ] out of there's a human
dangling like a piece of tenderloin so
right now he's they're above the water
not even touching the water
because when you go parasailing they'll
take you up and down the entire time
and they're on their way down that's
nuts well that's a
worst case scenario for you on vacation
that could be anything that breached the
water dude and i'm saying that's a great
white i said it
yeah great whites are usually ones that
breach the water like that yeah they
jump high
that would be a nightmare a nightmare
well that's like that's already perilous
anything nightmare because once the
original
take off like damn this is sick then 20
minutes later like
yeah i'm ready to come down and he's
like all right we'll bring you down and
they start wheeling you in then the
shark goes you know what would make this
better
if you were doing this with one leg if
you were doing this with one leg
that's like in queensland there's this
really beautiful beach
and then there's a cove called crocodile
cove
it's in queensland but there are no
crocs there and nobody gets attacked but
there are salties there are big
saltwater crocodiles
and so this these two girls they're
they're on a
girl's vacation she's in the water in
this beautiful water and a little bit
it's at night and she just gets taken
away oh yeah she just gets dragged away
by a giant saltwater cocktail
it found nature they found it and it was
a [ __ ]
50s yeah it's a monster i'm not going
near that [ __ ] water
i don't care if it never happens it
happened i don't know if someone was
like hey man you know 20 years ago they
found a salt water crop i ain't going in
the water say less yeah
[ __ ] somewhere else you guys take your
kids to the beach
well yeah you do i do they don't go deep
in the water i was in costa rica
and the guy i couldn't believe this i
see a picture
it's a 20-foot crocodile on the beach
and i go
where is that he goes it's here actually
this morning i'm not kidding
and the river estuary is there and it's
100 meters over there like well my kids
are playing in the water they go yeah
they'll leave you alone oh no they won't
it's a crocodile
no they won't and you they're on the
beach and they're setting themselves in
the morning
i'm never going in the water also can i
see your degree yeah do you have a
degree in crocodile yeah you know about
the apex predators is that an app on
your phone you can look up you [ __ ]
idiot
what else you got jen all right i think
you guys would be interested in this one
um a 26 year old woman well yeah
she's hot and she's back oh
she is bad um who
hired her to work around these inmates
so you know what you're signing up for
that's like the escape from dannemora
except for she's hotter than well
it's safe for dan morris she looks like
a warlock so it's not
just she [ __ ] all the inmates yeah but
she's hot the escape from dannemora girl
was like take what she could get
this girl i mean i'm sure she had her
pick of the lips yeah
so this twenty six year old woman wow
um she worked at fresno county jail
and when she was let go back
in december 2019 there was an invest an
investigation that was launched because
they found that a particular cellmate
had
alcohol drugs razors and a cell phone in
his cell
they later found out his face they later
found out that he was in a
relationship with this woman wow and
i guess from his statement
she used to cut a hole in her uniform so
they
would be able to have sex quickly it's
very hot and what's this guy look like
we don't know what that guy looks like
and apparently i've seen before
she had sex with him in a cell in front
of 11 other inmates at one point oh
she's down
mm-hmm i mean she used to sneak him a
bunch of stuff and then she would also
tell him hey
your cell's going to get checked on this
day this day and this day so you knew i
had
weird yeah no [ __ ] also the guy who
hired her he's like yeah you big tits
that's cool this will work out
i got no i got inmates no judgment no
judgment
i had to i also would you think was
gonna happen her lawyer is currently
saying that she
it was not in the right state of mind no
woman that
cuts a hole in her uniform to [ __ ]
faster she's a free right statement
they're also saying that she had marital
problems at that time and
that's what led to do we know like the
guy looks like who she was [ __ ] up
not as of now but i'm very curious too
trying to find out that's some
guess come on cause what if he's like
felon bae remember the guy
the model guy who uh went viral i don't
think that's the case
what are you thinking a lot you know i
know what you're thinking i know exactly
what you're thinking i'm thinking
about the guy who runs the yard you
think about some black i'm brown crime
that's what you're talking about the guy
who runs the yard
because i'm sure you have to fight for
her love and this guy el capitan
well wife beater there are some good
looking guys all they do is train they
just work out all
he has nothing else to do but but
[ __ ] glamour her and get his dick
so i got him tuesday clamor she's gonna
give him a cell phone it's gonna be
boost mobile be cool
it's not surprising that happens with
human beings they're around each other
and she's an attractive girl
he's locked around these dudes probably
a young dude himself
they're talking or i don't see i don't
think he's that he's a bad boy
i don't think he's that young he might
be a magician he's an old junkyard dog
got some got some problems got some
great grey in the hair
yeah live the life yeah got some scars
uh huh
and stories got some stories i guess she
didn't get pregnant so her lawyer is
currently asking for leniency but the
judge says that he went through
the cell phone and looked at
conversations between the inmate and her
the judge says that she shows no remorse
for what she did
she actually boasts about being
uh with this inmate and so he's less
likely to be lenia on her but why why
remorse like she probably liked the guy
and he liked her and we can't have that
though you know
yeah but like do you have to be like
judges saying that she put everybody who
worked at the jail in
jeopardy because he had razors that's
the biggest thing yeah you can't have
that either but raises for shaving
no raises for like mates you don't get
any big problems yeah
we can't have inmates with racers well
she's giving him shanks
yes oh no we can't have that no yeah oh
yes we have no clue what the guy looks
like i know she's freaking
really attractive which is weird looking
he's a lichen i'm just being honest
lock me tina gonzalez of lamore that's a
hell of it
what is the word um mug shot
i don't think they will love it that's
her worst day picture yeah i think she's
oh that's actually their picture's
terrible though
not terrible i'm still into that
yeah there's my boy getting his dick
sucked this coroner's office so i feel
bad he's got a snarl
he does yeah he's living the life man
yeah
i wonder if the guy was on like death
row or something the my thing is you
know you're gonna get caught yeah
what does that guy lose was the guy that
has brian kellen's hair down there
it's all corner stuff that sucks brandon
that's a [ __ ] up thing to say i don't
have a giant hole
yeah no i don't not when i do this
and i do this a lot you guys have the
same barber
god damn it it's gone and it's gone
what else do you get that's amazing
um this one oh we already did this one
okay oh do you already have that
chocolate yeah i had that yeah that
thing is so sick
i mean it's an airplane but we'll
pretend it sure is an airplane
yeah but if it can just take off like
that
that's pretty badass all right let me
figure out here oh you guys are talking
about pop-tarts this is kind of crazy
so during jerry seinfeld is going to
direct a thing called
unfrosted on netflix which is about
pop-tarts
is it going to be similar to that movie
the founder based off the guy who found
mcdonald's
i don't know did you did you hear about
did you guys hear about the guy who
uh supposedly invented flaming hot
cheetos have you told this story on the
show before kind of
you know like he was a jam invented
flamingo he was a
janitor at fritos lay and then this is
his story
then i'll fill it in so then he said
when
they would close up obviously he had
access to everywhere he came up with the
idea of flaming hot cheetos came with
all the ingredients brought it to the
board
presented it like damn not only a
janitor but this is a great idea we're
going to run with and obviously flip hot
cheetos makes a gillion dollars
he's for the past 10 years he's been
going on motivational talks around
colleges campuses everything blown up
his instagram everything like that from
rags to riches story
well then frida lays came out because he
started to impress and like
this never happened oh boy and he's like
yeah dude they're like
no it didn't and he's like we talked to
all the board members you never
presented anything to us
we have the team that created the
flaming hot cheeto
uh spices we have all the information
all the you know back logs all the stuff
the entire process that to get this done
like this never happened
we're like you know he contributed to
cleaning the facility but you never
invented flame heads there's some people
like that there was a guy in new york
he had a whole story yeah there was a
guy in new york city
who ran a parking lot and you would park
in he had a suit he had a parking
parking attendant
and he would take your twenty dollars
now he did that
apparently for 18 years until finally
somebody was like that's not
your parking lot and he i think he went
to
puerto rico or somewhere and he he
amassed
918 good for him thousand dollars yeah
we'll just take people's cash just every
day
only just every day and then yeah i got
you you know like that and parked
before so like this is a free parking
took 18 years because somebody you know
he just figured out that nobody cared
about that [ __ ] yeah this guy
that the flaming hot cheeto guy is
strange man that is
that's amazing [ __ ] flaming hot
cheetos indeed
all right you guys seen this yet carlos
mencia
criticizing joe rogan about him saying
like in the you know the whole cancel
culture so the headline reads carla
mencia thinks it's ironic that joe rogan
the guy who canceled him now complains
about cancer culture
here's a different carl smith yes is
this is like
lance armstrong calling usada uh
you know that you soda canceled lance
armstrong dude you were cheating
there's a difference between culture and
people rallying around it
over you know whatever and then you just
stealing jokes
and bullying comics and somebody calls
you out on it and you
you know somebody made a video in your
career taking a hit because you were
stealing
jokes and somebody made a video that's
not very cool
[ __ ] and then it's up to the public to
decide cancel culture is different bob
yeah
that's like literally like lance
armstrong calling you soda cancel
culture no it's not cancelled culture
yeah you were championing
i think brian redband made that i think
it was him
that was very hard to deny you know and
and i don't think carlos mencia really
took the narrative i love this article
if it makes
men see a feeling better rogan has
plenty of critics on his own prince
harry giant [ __ ]
and john oliver okay they criticize
through because people want to follow
those two i have no idea what has prince
harry
ever done what has he ever done in his
life
i haven't even heard of him he was
concerned he was no no no no not prince
harry though
was he critical of rogan though what did
he what did he say about robert when
rogan came out about the vaccine
called rolling an idiot oh
yeah dude you're famous because your mom
what are you doing you were giving a
[ __ ] silver spoon
shut up take your money all right for
spotify deal with your with your wife
come on dude all right they're making it
there's never been anything more
disappointing in the royal family than
prince harry
and he has a tough gig you're famous for
being famous
he has no skill no talent you're famous
for being famous
and you're criticizing somebody who's
talented so it doesn't work
you know what the one thing i say i'll
give him is that he did he did actually
see real combat and he
he he didn't though he didn't though he
flew helicopters for real
he could not be never saw combat but he
was just but you have to
no but he was he was rank-and-file with
the other soldiers and
and recognized so nobody denies that he
like he really did he really was
in the military and went through
everything everybody else did you have
to well i mean
but he he he's he's a dude you know he's
a dude like he's a guy
i think that he's heard him lately he's
not i've not heard him he's not i don't
know i'm way off yeah
wait i've not heard him lately he's the
biggest woke [ __ ] there really he's the
most disappointing royal family member
there
of all time besides that uncle who was
like on epson island but yeah the whole
thing with uh
his wife saying that you know they had
problems with the
this color of the baby skin you are not
even you you might be half
an african-american but you're also just
a hot-looking woman
who could be any race i i mean this this
idea that you're
you're dealing with racism it's so weird
to me yeah just like again no talking
about
got caught on a prince harry got caught
his eye took him away from his family
the royal family now they're living and
then spills the beans and saying things
that are kind of
it's like that's the house of windsor
that stood for a thousand years ago yeah
the royal family's like
what yeah the [ __ ] is happening right
now keep their mouths shut about things
i don't know the whole thing was really
strange to me
alluding to things for attention which
is what you see now trying to get a
spotify deal yeah
you got it congrats yeah i don't know
enough about them
to really you know judge them but i do i
do remember thinking that it was like
this
really elegant kind of thing whatever
but then people told me later on they're
like the kardashians of
there's a lot of money in victimhood
there's a lot of money in being
professionally out
how else would he get attention go
what's he gonna do
go yeah i'm not gonna tell you something
you don't know there's no
life experience right
yeah it's almost like a curse like
there's no it's almost a hard to avoid
you know no you almost feel bad for them
and then they're trying to create
headlines and [ __ ]
sell a podcast which they did for a
gillian dollars
yeah but who's going to listen to that
do they have big numbers on that podcast
i don't think so because all afternoon
like [ __ ] this guy so who's gonna listen
americans don't give a [ __ ] about prince
harry and his wife well not a podcast
i'm not going to tune into that to hear
well they have a podcast together yeah
what would you do
for any of it what are they going to
tell you yeah that's
a little strange i don't know all right
moving on
this uh brennan you know how to you know
about this way more than i do
it's a big deal so ncaa uh forced to pay
their athletes
is that right yep that's happened now
yep here's where it gets so they're not
paying them a salary there's none of
that but they can do like autograph
signings they can make they can sign
with an
agent they can do um certain things to
earn
income you know the so ohio state's not
gonna pay the quarterback but that
quarterback can
you know do autograph signings and other
[ __ ] to make money now barstool recently
started a bar stool athletics branch
where they are sponsoring athletes now
we've had people reach out like lacrosse
players reach out to
to me oh that's interesting sponsorship
yeah
wow that's dope i've had a friend who's
like a really like really good baseball
player to reach out about it too
where does he play it uh uri it's like a
good baseball school
okay he'll go he'll go somewhere oh
you're drafted yeah
he's like the top of that that's a
[ __ ] too like you might get
drafted but getting called up to the
majors
that's a whole nother thing just like
the nba and stuff all pro sports are
tough
yeah well a day after this broke uh
master peace son
signed a two million dollar deal but
here's where the ncaa is like yeah they
can do
you know they can make money off
endorsement stuff like that here's where
all these kids are gonna make money like
the number one
college athlete which is that is
probably surprising for a lot of people
the number with like the most followers
on tick tock and all that stuff
is a gymnast from lsu oh wow um so
her her girl right yeah her family put
up a big billboard
in times square oh livy done yes girl's
gorgeous
yep but she has the most follow so like
she's gonna make millions off her tick
tock
endorsement tick tock for her
should make millions now wow holy [ __ ]
she's
super pretty well how old is she 18 or
19.
gorgeous and then a high level gymnast
mm-hmm but she'll she'll make millions
here they're they're going to make
millions off their social media ncaa
they're too old to figure it out but
like the the captain of florida now he's
going to make
so much money off endorsements off
social media the cabin in florida
i'm just saying like all these big level
guys are gonna make so much money yeah
good here's where it gets dicey so let's
say let's say your son finn
right has a football scholarship to
stanford cal ucla usc
university of texas lsu uh florida
florida state
and he's he's getting these endorsements
i say he's getting
a let's just call it even a million
endorsements well
if you go to a school in california you
can pay
half that's going to the state of
california if you sign with florida
you're taking all that
so if you're a big five-star recruit
where are you going to go oh my god how
do you think it's going to affect
sports [ __ ] that's amazing i never
thought of that
if so if tiger's some baller and he's
like dad i got a million dollar
offer if i sign within these schools
it's like well
do you want to give half it to the state
california or do you want to keep it all
and go to texas i mean yeah use that to
pay
so what do you think's gonna happen in
california sports dude it's good [ __ ]
and and then california is gonna have to
go if you guys wanna compete you gotta
bring your taxes down
and i'm a fan of that or not or they're
like no we'll just keep charging
everybody more taxes yeah we don't give
a [ __ ] about college sports
but people move to states where it's
cheaper to do business
california is if you're a college kid
dude and you're making a million dollar
endorsement you're not
signing with usc you're saying with the
unc texas when you have a business
in california you're getting sued for
everything
just because well and you have to have a
lawyer when you're in texas not so it's
different cultures it's really
interesting i think it depends what
you're into
yeah you're so [ __ ] up california is a
very expensive place to do business
it just is for sure
all right uh keith oh you know you know
what athlete would have made the most
money
so here's where it gets nice so now
reggie bush is like dude now kids can
get paid and they can take money
give me my [ __ ] heisman like remember
they took the heisman from
reggie bush but never took the heisman
from o.j simpson who committed murder
and was convicted in the court of law
they let
oj keep his [ __ ] heisman after he
murdered two people
but then reggie bush took something he
was acquitted that's the difference
right he was found guilty in civil court
yep
so like how how far how are they going
to deal with that like
you have reggie bush and these coaches
that took money that are
suspended for [ __ ] ever like how far
are you gonna go back
i don't think they go back at all i
think i'm like those were the rules of
the time this is the new time that's how
it is
but you know that i'm the person who
they i might have been fox sports who
made who would have made the most money
if these was around when they were
playing who
who do you think where uh sports tim
tebow
he's he's the top three i think tim's
two or three
uh matt liner it's a football player how
do you say matt leonard but you
didn't know um juju smith schuster well
for sure lebron james mm-hmm didn't go
to college though you know he didn't did
he went right from 18 yeah how dare you
again
um kobe bryant either didn't either
college
i would have to say it's a football
player correct okay so it's a football
player
and it would be a running back nope nope
it would be a quarterback
and that would be not drew brees
no but it could be the
guy called peyton manning i was going to
say peyton manning
peyton manning would have made the most
money yeah tim t will i think number
three
wow wow okay
so kobe bryant kevin garnett and drives
me crazy but that's fine no i said not
he said not those guys because then you
said lebron james no but i said that
i'm testing you yeah i realized you'd be
like
okay you guys ready so yeah so keith
sweat you guys remember keith sweat
right
no body the song twisted yeah
him and bobby brown did reverses um well
they kind of compete
yeah but it's funny because i guess
keith sweat got really drunk
right of course so i'll play some of the
clips here bobby brown
is thick and not a cool way hold on
now who's that that's this is keith
sweat and actually i don't know how old
he is but he looks pretty good for his
age
yeah and he's doing oh no
oh i'm sorry is that chris tucker
[Music]
it does look like her sucker
they say singing the sarah yeah
is that him now that's him well this is
true that's drake's song that he played
[Music]
oh he's hammered
[Music]
he has hits though he does we just
didn't see him
bobby is so thick i know that's bobby
brown yeah
that's crazy bodied up
[Music]
these verses are nice oh bobby brown
he's walking diabetes now he is no
and then he says something here to the
dj
is that drama from ridiculousness he's
in shape
homeboy's in shape what do you say to
him he would snatch his
he goes he said that by this jewelry but
he would have you know jacked his
jewelry back in the day just out of
nowhere
just said he would have robbed the dj
cassie back in the day
i would have got it i got you he's all
walked around
wow well let me see one more i think
this is the same one yeah the same one
when
but that's fun that's awesome they're
doing these versus battles now the old
old school yeah yeah
the rap ones are good um so
how do you pronounce it bibi rexa she's
so fun
yeah so she did this uh viral tick tock
video about her weight so apparently
she's well here uh this is what she
wrote
or this is what she said uh how much you
think i weigh
and then no one's business because i'm a
bad [ __ ] no matter what weight and then
she says
let's normalize 165 pounds apparently
she's 165.65 i'm not
so i'll show you the video let's see her
that's her that's her yeah but she's
phenomenal
i know okay i'm not afraid of 165 pounds
at all
god dawg yeah
there are you know how many guys have no
problem with that you know how many guys
have zero problems
all of them but little nausea all of
them all of them all of them
about that she went viral a while back
because there were a bunch of designers
who said that they would
they refused to dress her for red
carpets because she was a at the time
she was a size six and they said that
was just too big that's what they said
that's what she's saying
she says i don't believe i know i kind
of have a little bit of a
uh and then a few months later there was
a videographer that she used to work
with really famous guy
uh who his text message is leaked
calling her a fat pig or a refrigerator
well yeah he was just like fat shaming
her even though she hired
her again wait no i think refrigerator
was what kesha's producer called she
walks
down like that she walks the room and
everybody looks at her so i i i can't
hear this is her just kind of being like
she knows she's fine as [ __ ] yeah let's
normalize 160. yeah
you know you're a bad baby yeah let's
not let's just want to remind you you've
had a hard time here
she's so bad he's gorgeous guys guys
you get you you choose the guy you want
it's not she has 6.5 million [ __ ]
followers on tick tock yeah stop it
yeah super stop it with this stuff let's
normalize
embarrassing five yeah if all 165 women
look like you would be
you know she looks she doesn't like
attention right she's not she's not into
attention
i always i always suspect that stuff how
tall is she
six eight you got twenty pounds
it's a big guy too light in the ass you
cannot come to her like five
no way five five 165
yeah she's got she she's running back
that's she's hot
there you go she's no she's a third down
running back she's got she's got
some running in my bed strength yeah
that's a yeah she's got some strength
yeah okay there's a uh update on that
guy ollie london who
identifies as korean okay the only
reason i bring this up is because look
how he
he looked before so this isn't before i
didn't realize
that's him before that's him before
that's a very british man yeah that's a
very british man
and he looks uh like a like a very
regular british guy
yeah and there he is there he is now and
now is that him up there
now no that's who he wanted to mimic you
oh that's what that is park jim
that's it from [ __ ] i don't know wait
wait
wants that's how he wants to look
yeah yeah he idolizes that this is
probably your daughter's idol right now
yeah by idols i mean like celeb yes yeah
now that guy is
that guy is uh he's a very pretty man
huh yeah yes
yes women go crazy straight man or yes
we don't know as far as we know as far
as we know
he struggles with his pronouns there is
a there is a feminine the korea is a
very
macho patriarchal society except for
k-pop
yes i was going to say but there are but
it does seem that young
gals dig these very androgynous looking
korean
but he's not being like korean men in
general that
go to work for a living aren't literally
having that guy over to hang out
you know they're kind of like he's not
invited they're unicorns yeah he's not
invited
nah he's a [ __ ] unicorn they don't
like tattoos over there dude yeah
and they're they're korea is
conservative as [ __ ]
just one yeah korea is very conservative
oh i watched uh
i think it was a uh what not a 30 for
30. i forgot was there's this kid
such a sad story he's playing baseball
he was good too playing the
pros did all right they got back down to
uh
the double a's and then you know just
[ __ ]
had the touch of the dark arts just got
super depressed
was like i don't want to do this anymore
i decided to commit suicide
and so he shot himself like this boom in
the head
but the thing is the i'm not even
laughing the bullet went through
you know no they're like ricocheted out
and so
he so he shot himself passed out and he
said he woke up and was like
why the [ __ ] am i in the same spot i was
in before i did this
and say he was like looking around oh
[ __ ] i'm not dead
he's like god damn it and then he was
like then right there to decide like
do i want to live or do i want to die so
i'm gonna live it's gonna be a fight now
that i shot my [ __ ] self in the face
so he's like do i pick the gun up and
shoot myself again to finish it
but he called the cops and so the cops
were saying anybody who shoots himself
in the head
you know aren't gonna call the cops so
they thought it was like a setup yeah so
the cops come like ready to
they got their guns out they come
through and they have the video of the
cop cam and he was a professional
baseball player dude like good [ __ ]
player
cops come in the house and the cops like
uh there's blood
everywhere right and he's like the pain
kicked in i guess finally
he was in so much pain and because the
you know the trauma
his eye was like head was like swollen
swollen shut
and the cop goes uh comes and goes
anybody else in the house he's like no
he didn't tell you
he shot himself he's in pain and the
kids like he said on the
couch and he's like no he's like there's
no kids or wife he's like no it's just
me man i tried killing myself
and the cop goes why would you try
killing yourself and he goes up because
i hate myself
the cops like all right let's get you
out of here and then now he's
better got some treatment and stuff like
that but he lost his eye
so now he has no eye everything else is
normal fake hip's correct everything's
normal
just don't have an eye and he has an eye
patch and he's trying to get back to
baseball
i'm just nuts yeah trying to get back to
baseball one eye is very tough
probably not gonna happen no yeah how
old is he yeah he was young like 24
25. there's a similar story where some
girl tried to kill herself because she
had you know
she was depressed and all that stuff so
she had a shotgun i think and try to
shoot her head yeah but she just blew
her face off
so she had to get a face transplant and
then she wanted to live again yeah
that's
afterwards it's terrible face
transplants
oh my god if you ever see them it's so
no
it's tough to look at man it's not there
yet we'll be able to grow faces back
eventually but wear masks do do family
opera
do phantom of the opera but full mask
i don't know ideas here is the stuff
they're doing now oh my god so
juicy like off uh the movie hannibal
it's a little issue you've seen him
have an issue yeah yeah it's juicy you
gotta find a face that's right
this podcast brought to you by uh better
help
and they have to take you know the face
has to take yeah to your face
that's terrible anyways yeah do you guys
remember uh home improvement
jonathan taylor thomas yeah okay
that's him before right so this is girls
this is just him
it's just an interesting thing because i
guess he was never on camera for like
the last eight years no one knew what he
looked like but he looks just completely
different he like disappeared
he you did yeah he went back to school
he went and got an
education yes he did but then after that
completely gone right so this is
him now looks completely different
there's nothing wrong it's just weird
that he looks so different usually when
you
age you look the same but just with
wrinkles and stuff but he looks
completely different
are you sure that's the same man that's
what it says
i saw multiple i saw multiple articles
the first one his
nose is completely that's a standard new
yorker there's no
that's a standard new yorker he was the
even the lips aren't the same why was
his lips then out
that's a good question but then he's
like puckering up for that little jewel
as you get older though your lips get a
little thinner i used to have a full
mouth
so so they said there's no [ __ ] it's
so hard to believe too but there's
multiple articles on this that's him
buddy
and this is on page six dot com that's
him holy
[ __ ] he's not giving me a thousand
guesses i would never guess either well
his lips are pretty full there yeah yeah
he just was tan
just doesn't look like he's that
interesting what happened to the chair
he didn't look like he's any
exercise and by the way he he vapes and
he's doing his thing so
i mean if you're out of the spotlight
just home all day you don't get that
much tent
two little dogs huh two little poops wow
that's nuts
yeah this is like so different the other
one's in prison
yeah for a domestic violence really yep
or here at least he was arrested
for him the blanket that looked nothing
like any other number
is uh in prison so
yeah yeah i think tim is the only one
doing anything all right so nevada has
its first ever miss
us or transgender usa not
is she like thai or something like that
no no no thai ladyboy's a trick yeah
enriquez am i right
that's fair hey cataluna enriquez i see
you made out with one i didn't make out
with one dude yeah you did i never made
out with them
you did i said we were there and and and
brody stevens the god bless
the labor rose there and this lady boy
was
hitting on him and i said brody if you
take that gal home
you are not a gay man that is a that is
a female
through and through as far as i'm
concerned would you agree with it and
she is
gorgeous and i don't see one trace of
masculinity because
a lot of times you can see the hands the
structure of the
body not in this case at all and i was
like
that is now i may have said i would have
made i wasn't because
i would have where's record of you
tomorrow you're making out didn't want
to hurt her feelings
oh no that wasn't in thailand though oh
oh oh
my bad oh my bad i did i was a young man
i was a young man i didn't know what was
going on for him
and then he grabbed my hand she grabbed
my and then i and then i
you know i went back in so i wouldn't
hurt her feel it when you want her
feeling and then pretending to tell her
you didn't want to hurt her feelings and
he started sucking i kissed her a little
bit more
and then i got all right
let me see this one all right so just uh
first transgen
gender miss nevada left or right on the
right the right
and then she's going to be the first one
to qualify for miss usa or you know she
can actually enter it
i don't respect hate hopefully the
quality gets better there you go created
so many problems in this world but for a
while i've lived in silence and i've
learned to hate myself to the point that
i received so much hate that i just
prayed that i would never wake up one
day
well so anyways she's killing it now oh
here's her instagram
yeah i mean she's there's no trace of
like masculine
no that's what i mean would you date her
christian that's a beautiful
gal ah we just said there's no trace
i don't know i'm saying that you've got
that same energy better yeah
better questions you're drinking you've
got a couple drinks in you
you guys are out to dinner and you're
friends it's not a big deal
and then you get there you go she says
dude kiss me look at that and she says
why don't you ever kiss me i would have
no problem if you hooked up with me not
at all
not at all i'm gonna i'm gonna talk
about it on the podcast but i'm not
gonna
no she's that's uh that's a gal to me
man
i mean that's clearly somebody who
that's clearly a man who was trapped in
a woman's i mean a woman trapped in a
man's body and then did
look at science so i don't know
but there you go but christian uh you
never answered would you be down
if she's post-op then yeah maybe
maybe that's how long she doesn't have
bigger hardware than me like at the time
then i don't think there's anything
going on down there
i found about christian got a dick on
him well i believe that
a lot of guys who aren't that tall how
would you how would you know maybe your
brother told me
oh you got a peace on you that's like
his brother doesn't give him an answer
listen i will give it to christian he
does have a dick on it
he does all right good for you congrats
i know i mean you know you're you're a
short italian guy that makes sense
true we got to figure out what you're
working with yeah it's very important
for us
we're gonna have to take a little piece
on it yeah i know another bathroom
figure it out
yeah yeah you got a piece huh
congratulations that's
cool all right what kind of piece are we
talking about i mean we're talking
thick or dude like a hockey stick or a
tiny hair i was
thinking more like a uh nicer kielbasa
sausage kind of like yeah
around that the hockey sticks are kind
of skinny there's another one
there's a porn star named chris diamond
who's got a who's got a great piece well
he's a porno star yeah
and i was like uh that's like saying i
know this guy plays in the band's great
yeah yeah but he's he doesn't look like
he's he looks like he's a skinny guy
with a [ __ ]
mandingo on there well that's a whole
different synthetic dude it's in
he's still working too hi i just watched
him the other day he still shows up
shows up old face old grandpa face dick
yeah
yeah he's brazilian i think i don't want
to click on this so
yeah he's from somewhere just go to
images i know but it's going to show us
that's all right baby let's see what we
got let's see what we're working on
let's see what we got there you go oh my
god oh there you go he's got
and there's there's [ __ ] that's it i
mean come on a hand a hand for that i
mean and it's
uncomfortable oh yeah makes me feel
weird
yeah it's an uncut piece oh he is a big
i mean but congratulations to him
right it's a good sleeve tattoo and then
he's got that [ __ ]
handsome tail he looks like he's on the
2000 calorie diet
probably he's doing pretty well he's
skinny kids skinny skinny but then he i
think he's probably been
get him there yeah
a little weight yeah well there it down
there that's called horse hung yeah it's
called horse horse
but that looks uh yeah i mean it's long
yeah you got to give it up
i don't know what it's doing there the
pictures are the funny part because he's
looking for a
[ __ ] rich violence he's posing for a
fountain
what are you doing the water's gonna
come out there
so can you just stand there while i
sketch out what i want
in my garden i know that for sure what's
he doing here
well he's just he's resting his [ __ ]
board and creating content
chin well you know that mandingo from uh
i think he's from uh bang bros
mandingo
well now i heard something really oh we
know i'm thinking i might be thinking of
um
oh gee mud bone now man gingko am i
thinking of the black guy
yeah but there was one guy like that who
ended up being fake it was just
a poster now i'm going to tell you why
now that's mandingo now she's wearing a
lot of powder on her face oh
they made out gets on his face i'm
talking about he's a brazilian guy
well mandingo is the guy no that i don't
watch a tiger no there's a guy
i think that's not right i think you're
thinking of og mud bone well there's
that guy over there there's that very
thin guy
uh if you go just a couple over this one
you can also go to that one right there
man think oh yeah that is just natural
hey just put that's all natural yeah all
natty hey just put uh
what are you doing bros uh big dick
okay it's gonna be like a million people
no but i'll recognize
big dick yeah i mean that's nuts
is old dude no no
there's a guy with a with an impossibly
thick yeah but he's like
he's a bad guy that guy's horrifying
that guy looks so evil well that's the
yellow this is the same guy too
that actually looks like the gooey brush
is the yellow bastard
and then there's that guy with the
dreads what does that tattoo say
which one right there the girl or the
guy the guy
winner oh sinner that's a winner
all right well it's a living guys it's a
list none of these guys
i'm sorry dude god damn it i know
exactly who you're talking about i know
exactly who you're talking about
yeah there's that young kid yeah you'd
have to go to bang bros
yeah well yeah he's all over it you know
what i'm talking about yeah i don't like
that russian guy creeps me out
male porn stars situation all of it is
pretty cool there you go chin good
good uh you're welcome not this guy not
this guy no you'll know he looks very
foreign no he he looks brazilian almost
light-skinned
yes he's actually american though is he
american
you know what i actually know what
you're talking about now you don't talk
i do i do
yeah um brazilian
yeah male porn stars i think he's
brazilian
no he looks like these guys are all gay
you don't have a good boss you guys are
gay porn stars
so well that's not good
all of them are gay um you know what i'm
talking about
yeah i do i know he's a darker gentleman
has a goatee yeah yeah like
a pencil mustache he could even be
mexican he looks dominican or something
dominican does but i'm pretty sure he's
brazilian
and it's impos it's just it's impossible
it's an impossible
and he looks like [ __ ] he says i know
you're talking about dude i can't
believe i know you've never
gone an episode and not talked about
dong at one point or another and that's
just the way it is it's going pretty
deep this one yeah
yeah it's frustrating there he is no i
thought that was
wait wait go back up frustrating we
can't find the guy with the bald head
that
might be him no no no no i know what
you're talking about
does he have a like yeah yeah the kind
of hair or something
yep he really whatever that means are
you talking about nacho
no or not freddy no no no that dude we
don't watch 90s porn
all right he's talking about a new guy i
don't watch oh he's not new you'll skip
catch him
i'm sure the fans will let us know i
don't watch a lot of porn
i really don't this guy um nope none of
these
guys he's got like curly-ish hair right
yeah
i don't know what ethnicity is he was
like the main guy okay because that guy
right there's got a real piece on him
you sure it's bang bros no i'm not
no i sure ain't like this this is the
closest but darker right
well that guy looks that guy guy's
absolutely terrified
i mean jesus christ dude where are you
staring
god it's frustrating we can't find him i
know that's old
all right well we tried yeah i don't see
him
and he's brazilian now i'm curious he
looks very brazilian
oh that might be damn it i thought it oh
no no
you were too [ __ ] come on keep going
keep going up up
there's that kid with impossible piece
keep going you thought was this guy keep
no keep going
this is just a man standing keep well
there's jason love
oh that guy nope that's not him no no no
god damn it i mean i don't know who it
is
all right what do you what about him
though he's got a piece i mean you
brought up that white guy i was trying
to bring up this guy
oh it's that guy the brazilian male porn
the guy sitting on a chair that guy
that's the guy there he is that's
the guy now that's a great look and
that's a great picture
maybe he's not brazilian because he'd
definitely pop up yeah no
he's definitely not brazilian because
this is all very gay
yeah just really weird oh sorry can't
find him
that's all right i'm sure people let us
know it's amazing how
there goes my computer how essentially
mainstream it is
clearly yeah you got to clear your
history got you
yeah you got to clear that event or we
ended on those big days
i think that's it hi art everybody i
hope you learned
everything here yeah what are you doing
this weekend bros know what i'm talking
about oh yeah it's fourth of july
weekend fourth of july what are you guys
doing what do you got planned just
barbecue at the crib
all right what are you doing i'm going
to europe
uh that frustrates me for some reason i
know but i'll figure the next
two weeks i feel bad about that i really
do you should i do you left me for
entire years yeah
i'm not gonna leave you for two weeks at
least i'm not doing anything like start
my own
[ __ ] studio that i gotta put together
we figured out the uh
calabash uh fight companion show though
okay it's me
cody garbrandt josh the punk thompson
and uh
who am i freaking brilliantly riley
martin who's bradley martin
the big uh youtuber the fitness youtuber
he's been oh yeah yeah
brian wasn't here when he was on right
now no bradley martin
okay we're trying to get the studio done
before then for july 10th
just so fans know it's not like i'm just
doing it
without rogan i called rogan said dude
it was literally my favorite show to do
was fight campaign yeah
fight command was my favorite thing i've
ever done yep there's nothing better it
was me brian eddie and
rogan we'd have some whiskey and talk
about octopus for an hour while one of
the biggest fights in the world was on
can't do it anymore uh rogan i called
ronan's like dude i'd love to do him if
you're down to him he's like i'm just
too busy man i don't think i can do him
he said i'm just too busy
i said oh i'd love jim he goes do you
have my bus and do it i said all right
dude then i'm gonna do it
so that's what we're doing so for ufc
264 conor
first dustin poirier trilogy we'll do
the first calabasas
uh fc um it'd be on the thick boy
channel stick with three c's you'll find
us on there i'll promote it so you guys
see it too on my social media
but that is going down first one you'll
see 264 then the next one
we have some big guests lined up uh will
be for the deonte wilder
and tyson fury fighting i'll be here i
think that's the 26th
i'll be there i'll be there for that 100
all right i'll line that up for us
but this set it's gonna be so dope man
what do you see this thing i can't wait
i'll be there and uh and then i'm in la
first shows in la happening soon july
16th 17th ha ha
los angeles california come on out
almost all shows are sold out
july 16th through 17th then i'm in
tacoma washington right outside seattle
july 29th to 31st
august uh 12-14 las vegas nevada
grand opening of wise guys right outside
the strip there in las vegas nevada
rallied north carolina august 19th 21st
hey raleigh nope
refused to september 9th through the
11th san jose california
san jose improv and then i don't know
why it's not on there whoever created
this graphic i'm a slap in the face
san antonio is september 24th 25th
and that's at the bud light uh att uh
courtyard right there in san antonio
biggest shows i've ever done
one show on friday one show on saturday
uh
in order to get tickets you gotta use
the pre-sale code thick
thick with three c's we'll have special
merch there just for the san antonio
crowd can only get in person
special uh spurs inspired thick boy
merch
uh oh and if you get the premium tickets
for either the 24th or 25th show the
premium tickets there's 400 of them
uh it comes with a meet and greet i
don't think it says that on the tickets
but there will be meet and greets for
those premier shootings
all right i'm looking up july 16th 17th
ha ha
los angeles let's ride that's right i
got i got
that brazilian with the big day could be
there yep and i got houston
improv in august just signed i think
it's the 21st i'm not sure
improv yeah uh his name prov then i got
uh
i got this did you head to hartford
connecticut no i'm not doing that i'm
not all righty
hartford anymore uh hey guys um one
thing i always forget is
uh we are we we are running audio only
conspiracy social club uh
old podcast no because of youtube and
they'll they'll
ban us because conspiracy [ __ ] so but we
we're running the old episodes back
every monday
so if you want to listen to the audio of
that uh it's me and sam triply and we've
laid down some
he's so [ __ ] because i love sam yeah
we're not allowed to put it on youtube
if you go on youtube they're going to
ban you because they'll they'll ban you
you talk about like you're talking about
like vaccine conspiracy just talking
about everything sam
you talked about sam goes deep now i'll
flag you so what happens is so if you're
talking about like government officials
we talk about
we talk about everything sam talks about
everything and i try to debunk it right
but
the thing is yeah i created the show we
we get into these crazy
but some of them are so good and i was
like let's re let's run
because it was on patreon for so long
now we're on rockville exclusive you're
not oh
because we we jumped over to ross vimeo
took us off first for a minute what yeah
yeah what are you guys talking about a
lot it's whenever you talk about
conspiracy
vimeo well sam pulls no punches so what
happens is
what you know for a second we got we got
a little bit easier i know
hey your hands are your hands are all
over me so you guys are just telling me
it's crazy about that in new york um
so audio is available only audio only
yeah we run that back is raku
or rockfin rockfin.com rokfin.com
they're videos
yeah that's that's great video so we
have that going and then we have all
your old dates there and the ones you're
not done
all right all right love you guys we're
out